all right ted well as post pandemic life
begins to kick in
some animal shelters are now seeing an
uptick in people surrendering their pets
the main cause is their return from
remote working to actually going back to
the office
christian caceres is looking into what
you can do if you're thinking about that
difficult choice christian that's right
denise well you and i are both pet
owners and we know that it can be a very
tough and emotional decision but the
nevada spca wants to remind the
community that there are
options out there today we visited the
animal shelter off decatur and russell
where we found a large inventory of pets
including cats and dogs and rabbits
and we're told it's cat season and many
people are surrendering their
four-legged felines on a regular base
rabbits and dogs are also in that mix
because people can't attend
the pets as they make the transition
from remote working to heading back to
the office
we now have an uptick in calls regarding
owner surrendered animals
because of moving which has always been
one of the largest reasons why people
return their animals back to us
and we are very concerned and a surge
that's going to happen with the
residential eviction moratorium
exploration
well if you're thinking of surrendering
your pet there is a process first you
must make an appointment and when you
meet with a staff member from the nevada
scpa you can update them on the pet's
health and needs so
nothing is overlooked they say no
questions will be asked since
it's a very emotional and difficult
decision to make
now they did ask not to leave pets at
the door because of the hot weather and
it can obviously be very dangerous
now as a pet owner i know how this can
be a very tough process but we want to
remind you that
there are options if you have a pet and
if you are struggling or just going
through a bad period coming up at six
o'clock i'll explain some of the
resources available
completely free christian casadas 8 news
now